all right Cynthia Bravo Kahn is upon us
how are you feeling about it so far like
I'm all up in it it's about to go down I
have no idea of what to expect it's the
first one we're making history tonight
and I'm excited all right and season 12
is underway our two episodes in and
episode three should be very
entertaining the return of Nene in
Episode three how how does that go
because it's that return involves you on
a prideful you know what I will say you
know being the bigger person
I felt like for pride you know we didn't
really let our drama overshadow why we
were in New York for pride you know it's
coming you waited till you got back to
Atlanta did we get back to Atlanta
basically I we both you know you'll see
on Sonny's episode but I felt like we
were pretty poor job for the most part
but you know then things take a turn
and they you know go to the left go to
the right it's a bumpy road interesting
to see where it lands I did notice you
two were together for a People's Choice
Award promo which makes me think we're
in an okay place at least things are
always seems like they look things are
not always as Nene has had a lot to say
about you in the trailer and in
interviews saying there's a side to
Cynthia that nobody knows a nasty side
what's your reaction to that a response
to that there's a different side to
Cynthia's wishes season 12 there's a
happier side as a very engaged side and
a very living my best life side so you
know this season for me it's all about
you know me being a negative space I'm
happy I'm in love reciprocity is the
word for season 12 for me you will get
the energy that you give reciprocity
that lasts me any question I promise we
just sat down with her and she I'm gonna
give you a quote she gave us this show
has won Queen and a lot of princesses
what's your reaction to that you know
what I don't strive to be the queen of
the show so if she is the
self-proclaimed Queen then know sanneh
bad am but I've just said Queen owned
all right
it was so cool to see Noel open up about
discovering herself at college getting
to share that with the fans what's the
reaction been so far the reaction has
been overwhelmingly amazing
and I never had any ideas that it was
really attract as much attention you
know Noelle's not a housewife she is my
daughter we don't really focus on her
personal life I felt like it was
important for us but for her to tell her
own story you know we live in a world of
camera phones and people videoing you
when you're not looking and I didn't
want you know I want her to add on
something before she got out it because
you know in a reality show I'm pretty
transparent again Noel is not a huge
focus of you know of mine on the show
you know she's my daughter and you know
my job is to protect her but you know I
didn't want anything to get out there
and it appeared that we're trying to
hide this thing that like you know
there's a big secret and we're not
talking about it on the show so I
applaud her for putting it out there and
getting in front of it because when you
don't do it then it's almost like oh it
scandal like oh no well you know blew it
you know even though you know it's her
choice it's her life as she introduced
you to any of these special people she
mentioned she met yet is she out in LA
now we are we actually both originally I
was gonna save all your heart is out in
LA your man your daughter his home
address is in Los Angeles in Los Angeles
yes does that mean you're even closer to
making the move full-time well right now
we're back coastal let's just say right
now la is home base for me you know in
my business season I have to spend most
of my time in Atlanta obviously and then
that's when he's and
and right now this is his busy season so
you know Nolan era Nolan I really thank
you leave it at that
[Music]